Was ist los beim Rasenfunk, wir werden es euch sagen und zu Gast habe ich natürlich den lieben Frank.
Da lach ich mir doch einen Arsch ab.
Echt. Alles bla bla bla ist das doch. Alles bla bla bla ist das.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Zeit für einen Klassiker, aber im neuen Gewand und sogar mit Code Opener. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Servus Frank. Wir wollen sprechen über den Rasenfunk und was wir so getan haben im letzten Jahr. Unser kurzes Update und so weiter. Oft durch Hörerinnen Fragen getrieben. Warum haben wir uns denn diesmal gegen die Community entschieden, Frank?
Rechtfertige Dinge? Na, haben wir natürlich gar nicht. Aber wir haben gesagt, wir wollen das im Winter jetzt ein bisschen kompakt halten. Wir hatten auch unser Treffen, unsere Drei-Königs-Klausur, quasi nicht an drei König, aber erst vor zwei Tagen. Und darum haben wir gesagt, jetzt machen wir ein kompaktes Update. Versuchen so ein bisschen die Sachen reinzubringen, die ohnehin sehr oft auftauchen in den Fragen. Und dann können wir zum Saisonende wieder ein bisschen mehr, naja, detaillierter darauf eingehen, was dann wirklich noch anfällt und so. Und haben wir gesagt, das ist vielleicht die bessere Variante. Auch damit wir ein bisschen kompakter bleiben, weil für dich, Max, steht schon der nächste Termin an.
Ja, beim Kiosk hatten wir verschiedene Gedanken irgendwie, um das vielleicht mal kurz so ein bisschen historisch auszuholen. Am Anfang war der Kiosk eigentlich immer angetrieben von Max, muss man sagen. Max hat irgendwann schon den Wunsch geäußert. Ich glaube, wir hatten irgendwann mal mit Aufklebern angefangen. Die hat Max in Umschlägen verschickt. Also ging es los, völlig ohne dafür Geld zu nehmen. Und dann haben wir irgendwann gesagt, na Mensch, es wäre doch toll, wenn wir irgendwie Merchandise hätten. Und was können wir denn da machen und hin und her?
Du vergisst einen Punkt, Frank. Es war schon so weit, dass uns Hörer, ich möchte ganz lieb grüßen an dieser Stelle, dass die uns schon Merch gemacht haben und geschickt haben. Wo wir uns da irgendeinen Weg überlegen mussten, das dann wieder unter die HörerInnen zu bekommen.
Nicht nur geschickt, sondern ich kann mich auch an die Übergabe erinnern beim HörerInnen-Treffen. Nein, das war beim deutschen TK Schland in München. Da erinnere ich mich noch an ein Poloshirt, das ist heute noch im Schrank.
Ich habe es auch heute noch. Aber so weit war es schon und dann haben wir gesagt, na jetzt müssen wir auch noch mal einigen.
Genau, und jetzt müssen wir irgendwann selber was machen. Und dann haben wir es uns natürlich, wie es unsere Natur ist, nicht leicht gemacht, haben nicht die offensichtliche schnelle Variante gewählt, sondern den Deep Dive mit, ja, wir möchten ja möglichst ökologisch produzieren und so. Das könnte alles nachhören, darüber haben wir schon vielfach gesprochen. Dann sind wir in der Zwischenzeit, da erinnere ich mich an irgendeine Sommerklausur in einem Biergarten, haben wir Gedanken gehägt, das eventuell sogar ein bisschen vom Rasenfunk zu entkoppeln, mehr so allgemein coolen Fußballmerch zu machen und hatten verschiedene Ideen dazu. Letztendlich muss man sagen, nichts davon hat so richtig gut funktioniert. Wir sind sehr zufrieden mit den Produkten, Max für die Videozuschauer, an Max seht ihr den Hoodie, der unser letztes großes Produkt jetzt war und wir hatten schon Shirts, wir hatten die dritte Tasse mittlerweile, das dritte Tassendesign, Basecaps und alles mögliche, aber man muss immer dazu sagen, am Ende war es zwar cool, das zu haben und ich trage vor allem den Hoodie selber liebend gern, aber es hat nie funktioniert, daraus eine zweite Unterstützungs-Schiene zu machen, die neben dem eigentlichen Support so richtig funktioniert hat, weil dadurch, dass wir eben den Weg gewählt haben, wie wir es jetzt machen in der Produktion, die Produktion ist einfach wahnsinnig aufwendig. Die Vorbereitung dafür, das Design, das Absprechen der Produkte, wir müssen finanziell sehr stark in Vorleistung gehen, weil wir Stoffbahnen kaufen müssen, aus dem die näher dann die Produkte machen und dann den Druck obendrauf und so weiter. Am Anfang hatten wir selber noch angefangen, das zu verschicken und alles aus meinem Keller damals. Genau und das konnten wir mal auslagern, aber trotz alledem muss man sagen, es war immer okay, es war kein Draufzahlgeschäft, aber es war auch nichts wirklich daran verdient, in einer Form, dass wir sagen können, okay, der zeitliche Einsatz, den wir damit bringen, der zahlt sich aus.
Genau, im Grunde war es bisher so, was wir reingesteckt haben, nee, was wir bekommen haben, haben wir wieder reingesteckt und dann war es manchmal sogar weniger als ein Nullsummenspiel plus das Interesse von euch da draußen ist dann vielleicht doch nicht breit gefächert genug. Also es gibt schon Leute von euch, die sich mit Rasenfunk Merch eingedeckt haben und die sich auch freuen über jedes neue Produkt, aber die Gesamtzahl derjenigen unter euch, die ist dann doch gar nicht so groß, was eben dazu führt, dass wir jetzt schon auf vielen Produkten noch sitzen und wir jetzt die Entscheidung getroffen haben, Frank, der Rasenfunk Kiosk, so wie es ihn jetzt gibt, der wird eingestellt. Das wird noch eine Weile dauern, aber wir verabschieden uns zumindest von dieser Art Merch zu produzieren und haben jetzt aber natürlich noch ein Problem, wir müssen das Lager leer kriegen. Und was haben wir uns da einfallen lassen, Frank? Es ist so innovativ.
Ihr kommt nicht drauf, wenn ihr es hört. Wir werden ab dem Zeitpunkt, wenn ihr diese Sendung hört, alle Produkte, die wir im Lager liegen haben, sprich das sind alle Produkte, die keine sogenannten Print-on-Demand-Produkte sind. Ihr habt im Kiosk, wenn ihr schon mal da wart, wenn nicht, dann bitte schnell, bevor er weg ist, bestimmt auch gesehen, wir haben Poster, die tatsächlich auch ganz beliebt sind und sich ganz gut verkaufen, die haben wir nicht im Lager liegen, die werden auf Bestellung gedruckt und an denen ändert sich nichts, aber alles andere werden wir ab sofort mit 30 Prozent Rabatt versehen und hoffen, dass ihr es uns aus den Händen reißt, denn wie Max schon sagt, wir wollen es loshaben, ganz einfach.
Und man muss auch sagen, die Produkte, die es jetzt gerade im Kiosk noch gibt, also das sind vor allem zwei Tassenmodelle, gibt es noch den Hoodie, das Shirt und die wunderschönen Beanie, das ist, glaube ich, das Rasenfunkprodukt, das ich gegen die Tassen verwendet, inklusive meiner Töchter. Die wird es so nicht mehr geben, also das werden wir nicht nachproduzieren aus ganz diversen Gründen. Es kann sein, dass es irgendwann noch mal eine Form des Rasenfunkmerches gibt, vielleicht überlegen wir uns was für Sticker, wenn ihr sie unbedingt haben wollt, vielleicht fällt uns irgendetwas anderes ein. Wenn ihr zum Beispiel auch schon Erfahrungen habt zu Print-on-Demand-Lösungen, also wo eben quasi jede Bestellung erst dann einen Produktionsprozess auslöst, die ökologisch und auch ökonomisch halbwegs sinnvoll sind, also und vielleicht auch möglichst nachhaltig, schickt sie uns gerne. Wir haben da schon mal recherchiert, das ist jetzt allerdings schon eine ganze Weile her, aber wir wären sehr interessiert daran, denn Print-on-Demand könnten wir jederzeit machen. Wir wollen aber halt gewisse Standards, die wir gerne haben, eben was die Qualität angeht und was eben auch den möglichst fairen Herstellungsprozess angeht, die wollen wir nicht reißen nach unten hin. Wenn ihr da gute Tipps für uns habt, immer her damit. Vielleicht wird das dann unsere neue Lösung, die es dann ab irgendwann geben wird, aber was auf jeden Fall fest steht, ist in diesem Sommer macht der Rasenfunkkios zu und alles, was ihr jetzt da gerade kaufen könnt, was eben nicht die Poster sind oder die Sticker, werdet ihr so nicht nochmal kaufen können und jetzt räumt uns bitte das Lagerlehrer, ansonsten haben wir nämlich eine Anschlussdiskussion, die wir noch führen müssen.
Genau, sonst müssen wir in Zukunft Garagen anmieten und die Sachen da unterzustellen. Nur solange der Vorrat reicht, kiosk.rasenfunk.de.
Mit dem Rabattcode, nee.
Vielleicht mit Rabattcode. Unter Umständen, wenn ihr jetzt dieses Video guckt, dann seht ihr vielleicht ein Rabattcode, weil wir wissen noch gar nicht so ganz, wie das...
Oh Gott, muss ich den einblenden, Frank? Nein, da steht eine Videobeschreibung, Leute. Kommt, das schafft ihr.
Und wenn ihr schon da unten seid, dann lasst einen Like da.
Für jede Einblende muss ich einen eigenen Track anlegen bei Ultraschall. Das heißt, ich müsste dann quasi dann ein Video nur an der Stelle rausklippen, dann den Effekt Videoanblendung rüberlegen und das dann...
Ja, okay, klingt einfach.
Genau. Habe ich nicht vorhin noch gesagt, ich will es nur monetär machen. Das ist der Grund dafür. Also, das ist eine der großen Ankündigungen, neben eben dem, dass wir jetzt Moritz mit im Team haben. Und dann gibt es noch ein letztes Thema, über das wir mit euch sprechen wollen und das ist Trommelwirbel... Der Rasenfunk-Royal. Oje, Frank, wir muten unseren Hörerinnen vor allem...
Das Lustige, ich glaube, ich habe in der letzten Sendung dieser Art dir damit gedroht, dass wir über den Royal noch sprechen müssen.
Aber da konntest du schon sehen, dass ich genickt habe. Gott sei Dank kann man da schon ein Video aufgenommen.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr so genau. Aber das Lustige ist, dass du jetzt bei der Klausur vor zwei Tagen du mit dem Thema angefangen hast und nicht ich, was sehr gut war.
Also, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir wissen, dass Veränderungen immer schwierig sind, aber ihr habt die Feedumstellung geschafft. Ihr werdet vielleicht auch so manches andere, was wir auch mal so testweise jetzt verändern werden, hinbekommen. Feedback dazu immer gerne ins Forum geben. Stichwort eben zum Beispiel der Beginn von so mancher Sendung. Mal gucken, wie sich das weiterentwickelt. Ihr werdet auch das jetzt schaffen. Den Rasenfunk-Royal, wie es ihm bisher gab. Und damit meine ich nicht, dass über jeden Verein gesprochen wird. Das wird bleiben. Aber die Verpackung, nämlich, dass das sechs große Sendungen waren, ah, vier bis fünfeinhalb Stunden. Und dass da zum Teil auch Vereine miteinander vermengt wurden in Gesprächsrunden, die vielleicht... Manchmal gab es da wunderbare Brücken, die man bauen konnte. Manchmal war es aber einfach nur Zufall. Die lagen halt nebeneinander in der Tabelle. Oder, ich wusste, die Gäste verstehen sich gut. Die Verpackung des Royals, sie wird sich verändern. Wir werden in dieser Saison diesen Royal erstmalig anders machen. Und es wird aber auch einen Vorteil haben. Also, es wird nicht mehr so sein. An einem Tag erscheinen sechs Teile. Die sind dann insgesamt 24 Stunden lang. Oder ich glaube, das letzte Mal waren sogar 28 Stunden. Und ihr könnt die dann durchhören, so wie ihr wollt. Sondern es werden viel mehr Teile. Wir werden es aufteilen, so wie wir jetzt auch schon die Schwerpunkte machen. Das heißt, es gibt dann pro Verein einen Saisonrückblick. Die große Herausforderung wird sein, da dann die Zeit nicht zu überschreiten. Denn ihr wisst es ja, für euch sind es dann, ach Gott, es war ja nur eine Stunde, eine Stunde insgesamt. Aber für mich sind es ja 18 Stunden mit 18 Gästen und so weiter und so fort. Plus Postproduktion und so weiter. Es wird wahrscheinlich auch noch übergeordnete Teile geben, wie wir das genau machen, wissen wir nicht. Und was aber der große Vorteil sein wird, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich habe einen großen Vorteil und ihr habt einen großen Vorteil. Mein großer Vorteil ist, wenn wir die Gesprächsrunden auflösen, dann kann ich die Terminplanung des Rasenfunks schon vor dem 34. Spieltag machen. Bisher war es nämlich so, 34. Spieltag ab Pfiff, dann Saisonrückblick, also die normale Sendung, die früher mal Schlusskonferenz hieß. Wir alle wissen, die dauert ungefähr vier Stunden. Die lade ich dann noch nachts hoch. Irgendwann nachts um drei falle ich ins Bett. Und manchmal habe ich dann noch nachts die Terminplanung gemacht und manchmal erst am nächsten Morgen sehr früh, weil dann erst haben alle Rasenfunks-Gäste ihren Aufnahmeslot bekommen. Die mussten vorher ein riesiges Terminumfrage-Dokument ausführen und alle Verfügbarkeiten eintragen und ich habe dann die Gesprächsrunden und so weiter daraus zusammen glambüset. Und erst dann hatte jeder und jede ihren und seinen Termin und erst dann konnte ich mit dem Aufnehmen beginnen. Das war ein höllischer Aufwand, der zu tausenden Problemen geführt hat. Das wird sich jetzt verändern. Jetzt kann ich früher planen, weil ich ja weiß, ich nehme mit jedem einzeln auf, dann brauche ich nur die Verfügbarkeiten und baue mir dann mein Ding zusammen. Und das ist mein Vorteil und für euch der Vorteil, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, haben wir darüber diskutiert. In der Klausurtagung müsste man das jetzt dann eigentlich noch zu einem festen Termin veröffentlichen. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich ist doch jeder Saisonrückblick dann, wenn er fertig ist, fertig. Es ist sogar vom Vorteil, weil manchmal hatten wir das ja noch, dass dann jemand seinen Trainer noch entlassen hat, bevor der Royale erschienen ist, aber schon nachdem das entsprechende Vereinssegment aufgezeichnet war. Also der Royale wird früher kommen und er wird häppchenweise kommen und vielleicht ist das ja dann ja auch eine gute Nachricht für euch da draußen.
Ich finde es gut. Ich glaube auch, dass es gut ankommen wird. Es zahlt wieder so ein bisschen ein in diese Richtung, über die wir vorher schon gesprochen haben, die bessere Auffindbarkeit. Man hat dann eben eine klare Sendungssaisonrückblick Heidenheim und einen klaren Fokus. Hilft uns an der Stelle auch, glaube ich, was eben die Sichtbarkeit angeht. Hilft aber auch den Hörern oder vielleicht auch neuen Hörern, die bei YouTube oder auch in den Podcatchern gezielt nach ihrem Verein suchen, dann auch diesen Saisonrückblick dort punktgenauer zu finden. Und außerdem ist es auch für die Zusatzsegmente im Royale, sei es jetzt unser Gespräch, dass wir da jedes Jahr angedockt haben, das muss da ja nicht hin.
Ja, das wird im Zukunft immer ein Tribüngespräch sein, Frank.
Genau, es wird ein Tribüngespräch sein und es muss dann auch nicht dringend noch schnell zwischen Saisonabschluss und Royale-Veröffentlichung aufgenommen werden, sondern kann eben auch ein bisschen losgelöst davon sein, genauso wie vielleicht Taktik- oder Schiedsrichter-Segmente.
Ja, und man muss eben auch nicht mehr auf den Relegationsteilnehmer warten, der in der Regel dann in der Liga geblieben ist. Das hat ja bisher den Veröffentlichungszeitpunkt des Royales diktiert. Es war immer am Tag nach dem Relegationsrückspiel der ersten Liga natürlich und alles andere musste bis dahin fertig sein, dann ganz schnell möglichst einen Gast finden, der dann auch die Zeit hat, entweder nachts noch aufzunehmen oder möglichst früh am Tag, damit dann eben auch bis Abend alles online ist, weil allein der Veröffentlichungsprozess des Royales, der hat immer so rund drei Stunden gedauert.
Und mir ist auch definitiv wohler, weil der Grund, warum ich gesagt habe, wir müssen über den Royale reden, war ja eigentlich immer dein Stresslevel in dieser Zeit. Und da besteht jetzt zumindest ein bisschen Aussicht darauf, dass das ein kleines bisschen einfacher wird.
Das denke ich auch. Also ich glaube, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, auch das wird eine Entscheidung sein, wo wir dann im Nachhinein sagen, so wie schon bei der Feedumstellung, hätte man eigentlich schon früher so machen können, weil die Vorteile, die Nachteile dann doch überwiegen. Und ihr könnt ja trotzdem noch alles nacheinander weghören. Das ist euch ja völlig frei überlassen. Also der Royale wird anders aussehen. Und dann, da können wir jetzt noch nichts konkret ankündigen, aber dann wartet die EM auf uns. Ich glaube, ich kann für uns beide sprechen, Frank, dass wir uns da einfach sehr drauf freuen, dass wir extrem gespannt darauf sind, wie dieses Turnier ankommen wird, sowohl eben bei unseren Hörerinnen, auch generell die Berichterstattung, wie die sein wird. Wir werden natürlich wieder versuchen, es allumfassend zu besprechen. Also es wird wieder Vorschau, Rückblick geben, es wird tägliche Sendungen geben, aber die genaue Form wissen wir noch nicht, weil man so ehrlich sein muss, dadurch, dass dieses Turnier in Deutschland stattfindet und dadurch, dass es dann eine theoretische Möglichkeit für mich zum Beispiel gibt, bei Spielen vor Ort zu sein. Vielleicht ist die UEFA gnädig und akkreditiert mich für Deutschland gegen Schottland hier in München. Das wäre natürlich ganz fantastisch. Wann zeichnen wir dann die Sendung auf? Habe ich da gutes Internet? Wird da auch noch Video mitgeliefert? Keine Ahnung, das alles muss ich erst noch zeigen, aber ich glaube, wir freuen uns auf die EM. Das könnte auch ein sehr schöner, na nicht Abschluss, ist ja Quatsch, wir schließen nichts ab, aber so ein bisschen sind diese Turniere ja immer schon wichtig gewesen für den Rasenfunk. Wir hatten immer verschiedene Peaks, was quasi so Treppenstufen waren, wo wir unsere Reichweite erhöht haben. Das war immer der Rasenfunk-Royal und das waren immer Turniere. Und jetzt ist es eben seit einigen Jahren so, dass wir diese Treppenstufen nicht mehr sehen. Also wir machen dann eben zur WM 2018, die damals sehr, sehr umfangreiche Berichterstattung sehen, aber nicht mehr, dass sich dadurch jetzt wirklich so viele neue Menschen bei uns einfinden. Und vielleicht könnte die EM davon die Ausnahme sein mit allen Dingen, die wir vorher auch besprochen haben. Und generell muss ich auch sagen, ich freue mich auch einfach auf dieses Turnier, unabhängig davon, wie weit die Deutschen kommen, weil ich einfach sehr gespannt darauf bin, schafft das vielleicht auch die deutsche Öffentlichkeit, sich einfach an einem Turnier zu erfreuen, selbst wenn es vielleicht für das Heimteam nicht so gut läuft. Das könnte schon gut werden.
Ja, definitiv. Da bin ich auch sehr gespannt darauf, wie so ein bisschen die Gesellschaft damit umgeht. Auch fast 20 Jahre zurückblickend auf die WM im eigenen Land, wie sich die Dinge da verändert haben und wie der heutige Umgang damit ist.
Ja, und bei der ja auch wirklich vieles nicht gut war. Also ich habe jetzt erst neulich wieder einen Podcast gehört, wo es auch kurzzeitig um die WM 2006 ging und wo wieder nur das Sommerbällchen erwähnt wurde und nicht erwähnt wurde, wie eben mit Argentinien umgegangen wurde oder dann mit in Deutschland lebenden Menschen mit italienischen Wurzeln. Es war nicht alles toll zur WM 2006 und ich glaube, dass wir diese Schattenseiten sehr, sehr viel deutlicher jetzt bei diesem Turnier sehen werden. Einfach weil soziale Netzwerke die Art und Weise verändert haben, wie über solche Dinge berichtet werden.
Ich glaube, es ist viel mehr das hervorheben.
Es ist eine höhere Sichtbarkeit da. Wahrscheinlich ist dann auch die Herausforderung, das nicht über zu betonen, sich da nicht so sehr mitreißen zu lassen von den Extrembeispielen, die es ganz sicher 2006 auch gab, die wir aber ganz sicher damals oft nicht gesehen haben. Aber deswegen, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf und ich könnte da auch selber noch keine Prognose abgeben. Ich weiß nur, dass ich mich unheimlich darauf freue. Ich habe natürlich enormen Bammel davor, wie wir das alles hinbekommen, dieses Turnier zu stemmen. Aber das haben wir bisher noch immer gewuppt bekommen. Das wird diesmal auch klappen. Also EM 2024. Wir sind noch nicht ganz bereit, aber wir freuen uns schon drauf. Letzte Worte, Frank. Was haben wir noch nicht angesprochen? Was möchtest du den HörerInnen noch mitgeben?
Ich glaube, inhaltlich fehlt mir nichts. Ich wollte vielleicht noch mal so zurückblickend auf das letzte Jahr einfach noch mal Danke sagen für den großartigen Support. Die Zeiten sind gerade gefühlt, sagen wir das auch seit vielen Jahren, zunehmend schwerer so ein bisschen gesamtgesellschaftlich, auch wirtschaftlich für viele schön zu sehen, dass ihr uns trotzdem weiter unterstützt, dass der Bereich trotzdem sich für uns gut entwickelt und uns darin bestärkt, dass wir auf dem richtigen Weg sind. Ich hoffe, das bleibt auch in Zukunft so. Im Vorblick auf die EM vielleicht auch da die Bitte an euch, uns zu unterstützen. Nicht nur finanziell, natürlich finanziell, aber auch im Forum inhaltlich.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Haut damit rein. Sagt uns gern, wie ihr auf die EM blickt, wie ihr euch darauf freut, was ihr eventuell selber zu EM macht. Wollt ihr schauen, dass ihr Karten bekommt? Seid ihr vor Ort? Wollen wir sehr gern hören und mit eurem Input arbeiten. Definitiv.
Input auf der einen Seite und aber auch sehr gerne hier noch mal der Hinweis, empfehlt uns bitte weiter. Es kommt zu einer Floskel, sagt einem auch jeder Influencer da draußen, aber es ist eben nun mal die beste Form, in der man wachsen kann. Also wir haben alle möglichen Arten schon durchprobiert. Auftritte in anderen Formaten, Auftritte im Fernsehen und so weiter und so fort. Das immer am besten funktionierende Mittel, um neue HörerInnen zu gewinnen, ist die persönliche Empfehlung. Also nehmt es zum Anlass, packt euch eine Sendung, die euch besonders gefallen hat. Schickt die jemanden, empfehlt den YouTube-Kanal, wenn ihr möchtet. Das wäre schön. Ihr könnt es auch gerne bewerten auf den Plattformen, wo das möglich ist. Die Podcast-Landschaft, sie hat sich wirklich krass verändert, auch und gerade im Bereich Sport und Fußball und das wird mit der EM 2024 noch extremer werden. Wir können nicht mehr damit rechnen, dass allein dadurch, dass wir über jedes Spiel sprechen, wir gefunden werden. Wahrscheinlich wird eher das Gegenteil der Fall sein. Vielleicht sind wir sogar auch gar nicht mehr alleine mit diesem Ansatz. Wer weiß das schon. Also ihr könnt weiter unsere wichtigsten Influencer sein, indem ihr andere auf den Rasenfunk aufmerksam macht und vielleicht auch jene, bei denen ihr das schon mal gemacht habt, die aber gesagt haben, ich habe keine Zeit für drei Stunden Sendung. Vielleicht haben sie für manches unsere neuen Formate dann doch die Zeit, denn es ist ein bisschen zumindest kompakter geworden, ohne dass der Inhalt gelitten hätte.
Kompakt, genau.
Eigentlich ist es ja sogar länger geworden, wir haben es nur getrennt. Das war sehr schlau.
Sagen wir einfach, zugänglicher ist es geworden. Genau und da gibt es auch diesen Thread im Forum dazu, den wir im letzten Jahr als Input genutzt haben, der dann letztendlich zu den Feedänderungen geführt hat. Guckt da gerne rein ins Forum, wenn ihr Ideen habt, was wir noch tun können, um neue Hörer zu gewinnen. Dort ist der richtige Ort, uns das zu sagen.
Oh je, ich muss ganz viele Links setzen und ich hoffe, dass ich das nicht vergessen habe, weil die Links werde ich erst setzen, nachdem ich jetzt gleich die PK mit mir Künstler gesehen habe. Also ich schreibe mir mal lieber auf, dass ich da nochmal ins Forum gucken muss. Also hoffentlich ist alles verlinkt, was euch interessiert.
Alle Links unten in der Beschreibung bzw.
Alle Links, an die ich mich erinnert habe. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es war ein wunderbares Jahr 2023 mit euch und es wird ein ganz fantastisches Jahr 2024. Anders kann es gar nicht sein, so wie die Zeichen stehen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke dir, lieber Frank. Du weißt, wie immer, es ist ein Highlight für mich, mit dir gemeinsam hier zu sprechen.
Schön, dass ich wieder dabei sein durfte.
Ja, mal gucken, wann wir dann dieses Rasenfunk-Update das nächste Mal machen. Das wird natürlich nochmal die Frage, aber wir finden einen Termin und dann werden wir... Genau, irgendwann danach. Geht in den Kiosk, kauft den leer. Frank, mach's gut, bis bald.
Reißt uns das Zeug aus der Hand.
Ja, aber wirklich. Es wäre wirklich notwendig. Danke euch, danke auch für euren Support. Wir hören uns bald hier wieder und jetzt geht's wieder los. Das ist die erste Sendung im Jahr 2024 und jetzt könnt ihr euch darauf einstellen. Das rattert jetzt so durch. 68 Sendungen bis zur M-Funk-Show ohne Rasenfunk-Royale. Also, ich hoffe, eure Ohren sind gut geölt. Macht's gut, ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.